Pero en el otro lado de la moneda,
también se hace mucho daño,
cuando los padres sienten que el niño no puede tener éxito
a menos que el padre lo esté protegiendo en todo momento
y se involucre en todos lo que pasa y microgestione cada momento
y guíe al niño hacia algún pequeño grupo de universidades y carreras.
Cuando nosotros criamos niños de esta manera,
y digo "nosotros",
sabrá Dios, en la crianza de mis dos adolescentes,
tuve estas tendencias yo misma,
nuestros hijos terminan llevando una lista de chequeo de infancia.
Y así se ve una lista de chequeo de infancia.
Los mantenemos sanos y salvos,
y alimentados e hidratados,
y luego queremos estar seguros de que van a las escuelas adecuadas,
que están en las clases adecuadas en las escuelas adecuadas
y que sacan las notas adecuadas en las clases y escuelas adecuadas.
Pero no solo las calificaciones,
no solo las calificaciones sino los reconocimientos y los premios
y los deportes, las actividades, el liderazgo.
Les decimos, no solo entren a un club,
inicien uno, porque a las universidades les gusta.
Y marquen la casilla para servicio comunitario.
Muestren a las universidades que se preocupan por los demás.
(Risas)
Y todo esto se hace esperado cierto grado de perfección.
Esperamos que los niños rindan a un nivel de perfección
que nunca nos pidieron a nosotros mismos,
y como se requiere tanto,
pensamos,
bien, por supuesto que los padres tienen que hablar con todos los maestros
y el director y el entrenador y árbitro
y actuar como conserje de nuestros hijos
y entrenador personal
y secretario.
Y luego con nuestros hijos, nuestros hijos preciosos,
pasamos tanto tiempo empujando,
persuadiendo, ayudando, regateando, regañando, lo que sea,
para asegurarnos de que no están metiendo la pata,
de que las puertas no se cierren,
de que no arruinen su futuro,
de que tengan esperanzas de entrar
a un pequeño grupo de universidades
que rechazan a casi todos los solicitantes.
Y así se siente ser un niño con esta lista de infancia.
En primer lugar, no hay tiempo para el juego libre.
No hay espacio en las tardes,
porque todo tiene que ser enriquecedor, pensamos.
Es como si cada tarea, cada prueba, cada actividad
fuera algo decisivo para el futuro que tenemos en mente para ellos
y los absolvemos de ayudar en la casa,
e incluso no los dejamos dormir lo suficiente
siempre y cuando se estén marcando temas en la lista de chequeo.
Y con la lista de infancia decimos que solo queremos que sean felices,
pero cuando llegan a casa de la escuela,
lo primero que preguntamos es acerca
de su tarea y sus calificaciones.
Y ven en nuestra cara
que nuestra aprobación, que nuestro amor,
que su propio valor,
viene de un 10.
Y luego caminamos con ellos
y les damos premios como un entrenador para un concurso de perros,
(Risas)
para persuadirlos a saltar un poco más alto y un poco más lejos,
día tras día tras día.
Y cuando llegan a la preparatoria
no se preguntan: "Bueno, qué me gustaría estudiar
o hacer como actividad?"
Van con los consejeros y dicen:
"¿Qué tengo que hacer para entrar en la universidad adecuada?"
Y entonces, cuando empiezan las calificaciones
y sacan algunos 8,
o, por Dios, ni pensarlo, algún 7,
frenéticamente escriben a sus amigos
y dicen: "¿Alguien ha entrado en la universidad adecuada con estas notas?"
Y nuestros hijos,
independientemente de donde vayan a parar al final de la preparatoria,
están sin aliento.
Son frágiles.
Están un poco exhaustos.
Están un poco envejecidos antes de tiempo,
deseando que los adultos les hubieran dicho: "Has hecho lo suficiente,
este esfuerzo en la infancia es suficiente".
Y están fulminados ahora con altas tasas de ansiedad y depresión
y algunos se preguntan,
¿Esta vida habrá valido la pena?
Bueno, nosotros los padres,
los padres estamos bastante seguros de que todo vale la pena.
Parece que nos comportamos
como si, literalmente, creyéramos que no tienen ningún futuro
si no entran a ese reducido grupo de universidades o carreras
que tenemos en mente para ellos.
O tal vez, tal vez, solo tenemos miedo
de que no van a tener un futuro del que podamos presumir
a nuestros amigos y con calcomanías en nuestros vehículos.
Sí.
(Aplausos)
Pero si vemos lo que hemos hecho,
si tienen el valor de verlo de verdad,
verán que no solo hace pensar a nuestros niños que su valor viene
de calificaciones y resultados,
sino que cuando vivimos dentro de sus preciosas mentes en desarrollo
todo el tiempo, como si fueran nuestra versión
de la película "Quieres ser John Malkovich",
enviamos a nuestros hijos el mensaje:
"Niño, no creo que puedas lograr algo sin mí".
Y así, con nuestra sobreprotección,
nuestra sobredirección y con llevarlos de la mano
los privamos de la oportunidad de construir una autoeficacia,
que es un principio fundamental de la psique humana,
mucho más importante que la autoestima que reciben
cada vez que les aplaudimos.
La autoeficacia se construye viendo que las acciones propias llevan a resultados,
no...
Ahí va.
(Aplausos)
No las acciones de nuestros padres en nuestro beneficio,
sino cuando las propias acciones conducen a resultados.
Así que en pocas palabras,
si nuestros hijos desarrollan la autoeficacia, y la deben desarrollar,
entonces tienen que pensar, planificar, decidir,
hacer, desear, superarse, tratar y equivocarse,
soñar y experimentar la vida
por ellos mismos.
Ahora, ¿estoy diciendo
que cada niño es trabajador y está motivado
y no necesita la participación o el interés de los padres en sus vidas,
y que no deberíamos molestarlos?
Diablos, no.
(Risas)
Eso no es lo que estoy diciendo.
Digo que cuando tomamos calificaciones, resultados, reconocimientos, premios
como el propósito de la infancia, todo ello esperando
que algún día ingresen a un pequeño grupo de ciertas universidades
o a un reducido número de ciertas carreras,
es una definición demasiado reducida de éxito para nuestros hijos.
Y a pesar de que podemos ayudarles a alcanzar algunas metas a corto plazo
al sobreayudarlos...
algo como sacar una mejor calificación si les ayudamos a hacer sus tareas,
y así tener un mejor currículo de infancia...
lo que digo es que todo esto tiene un costo a largo plazo
en el sentido de sí mismos.
Lo que digo es que debemos estar menos preocupados
por un grupo específico de universidades
a las que podrían aplicar o ingresar
y mucho más preocupados por que tengan los hábitos, mentalidades, habilidades,
el bienestar, para tener éxito donde quiera que vayan.
Lo que digo es que nuestros niños nos necesitan
un poco menos obsesionados con calificaciones y resultados
y mucho más interesados
en que la infancia les proporcione una base para su éxito
construido sobre cosas como el amor
y las tareas domésticas.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
¿Dije tareas domésticas? Sí, tareas domésticas.
Pero en realidad, esta es la razón.
El estudio longitudinal más largo realizado en seres humanos
se llama el estudio Grant de Harvard.
Se encontró que el éxito profesional en la vida,
que es lo que queremos para nuestros hijos,
viene de hacer tareas domésticas en la niñez,
y entre más temprano se inicie, mejor,
el "súbete las mangas y ayuda"
es una mentalidad que dice, hay un trabajo desagradable,
alguien tiene que hacerlo, y bien podría ser yo.
Una mentalidad que dice,
voy a aportar mi esfuerzo para el mejoramiento del todo,
que es lo que te hace sobresalir en el lugar de trabajo.
Ahora, todos sabemos esto. Uds. lo saben.
(Aplausos)
Todos sabemos esto y, sin embargo, en la lista de infancia,
absolvemos a nuestros hijos de hacer trabajo en casa
y luego terminan como adultos en el lugar de trabajo
a la espera de una lista,
pero no existe,
y lo más importante, carecen del impulso, el instinto
para subirse las mangas y ayudar
y mirar alrededor y preguntarse, ¿cómo puedo ser útil a mis colegas?
¿Cómo puedo anticiparme a lo que podría necesitar mi jefe?
Un segundo hallazgo muy importante del estudio Grant de Harvard
es que la felicidad en la vida
viene del amor,
no del amor al trabajo,
el amor de los seres humanos:
nuestra pareja, nuestro socio, nuestros amigos, nuestra familia.
Así que en la infancia tenemos que enseñar a nuestros hijos como amar,
y no pueden amar a los demás si no se aman a sí mismos en primer lugar,
y no van a amarse a sí mismos si no les podemos ofrecer amor incondicional.
(Aplausos)
Exacto.
Y entonces,
en lugar de estar obsesionados con calificaciones y resultados
cuando nuestros preciosos hijos lleguen de la escuela,
o lleguemos a casa del trabajo,
tenemos que apagar la tecnología, guardar nuestros teléfonos,
y mirarlos a los ojos
y hacerles ver la alegría que llena nuestras caras
cuando vemos a nuestro hijo por primera vez en unas pocas horas.
Y entonces tenemos que decir,
"¿Qué tal tu día?
¿Qué te gustó de hoy?"
Y cuando su hija adolescente diga, "el almuerzo", como lo hace la mía,
aunque quieran hablar de la prueba de matemáticas,
no del almuerzo,
tienen que mostrar interés en el almuerzo.
Tienen que decir qué fue lo mejor del almuerzo.
Necesitan saber que son importantes para nosotros como seres humanos,
no por sus calificaciones.
Muy bien, están pensando, tareas domésticas y amor,
suena muy bien, pero por favor.
Las universidades quieren ver puntuaciones y calificaciones
y reconocimientos y premios, y en cierto modo, tienen razón.
Las escuelas de logotipos caros piden eso a sus aspirantes,
pero también hay buenas noticias.
Contrario a lo que los rankings de las universidades nos quieren hacer creer,
(Aplausos)
no tienes que ir a una de las escuelas de marca cara
para ser felices y tener éxito en la vida.
Las personas felices y exitosas fueron a la universidad estatal,
a una pequeña universidad que nadie conoce,
a la universidad de la comunidad,
a una universidad y los echaron.
(Aplausos)
La prueba está en esta habitación, en nuestras comunidades,
es la verdad.
Y si pudiéramos ampliar nuestras orejeras
y estar dispuestos a considerar unas pocas universidades más,
podríamos librarnos de nuestro esnobismo educativo
y aceptar esta verdad y luego darnos cuenta,
de que no es el fin del mundo
si nuestros hijos no van a una de esas escuelas de grandes marcas.
Y más importante aún,
si su infancia no se vivió de acuerdo con una tiránica lista de chequeo
luego, al llegar a la universidad,
la que quiera que sea,
irán ahí y harán su propia voluntad,
alimentada por su propio deseo,
capaces y listos para prosperar allí.
Tengo que admitir algo.
Tengo dos hijos que he mencionado, Sawyer y Avery.
Son adolescentes.
Y érase una vez,
creo que estaba tratando a Sawyer y Avery
como árboles bonsái,
(Risas)
que recortaba y cuidaba con cuidado
y formaba a un ser humano perfecto
que fuera lo suficientemente perfecto como para garantizar la admisión
a una de las universidades más altamente selectivas.
Pero entendí, después de trabajar con miles de niños de otras personas
(Risas)
y de criar a mis dos niños,
que mis hijos no son árboles bonsái.
Son flores silvestres
de un género y especie desconocidos.
Y es mi trabajo proporcionarles un ambiente nutritivo,
para fortalecerlos a través del trabajo doméstico
y el amor para que puedan amar a los demás y recibir amor
y el colegio, la carrera, la especialidad,
eso ya depende de ellos.
Mi trabajo no es hacerlos llegar a ser lo que quiero que sean,
sino apoyarlos a convertirse en sus maravillosos sí mismos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)